uh one thing we know won't happen
patrick mahomes won't be traded by the
kansas city chiefs
ever but one of the quarterbacks who
entered the league the same year he did
just two picks later also someone traded
up to get him it was the chiefs trading
up to get mahomes at 10.
texans trading up to get deshaun watson
at 12.
his situation is still out there
they had their press conference on
friday the houston texans
they made it clear in my assessment that
the door
is not bolted shut on a tray they have
zero interest in trading and well
you've probably got zero interest in
shoveling your your driveway today but
you'll still do it right
there's a lot of things that people have
zero interest in doing that they do okay
i won't quite go that far
your kid's old enough to work a shovel
by now but but the point is
i got the impression that it's not off
the table that it's still in play
and so we see the matthew stafford trade
and what the rams gave up and how that
deal went down
what does it mean for deshawn watson i
mean on one hand it kind of stretches
the rubber band a little bit it makes it
easier for people to get their brain
around the idea that trades are gonna
happen
but you know from the texans perspective
do they look at this deal and say hey
our price tag just went
up or do they say okay well we still
don't want to trade him
we're still going to sit back though and
see what kind of offers come in
and maybe this stafford deal causes
teams to
to accelerate what they're willing to
put on the table a little more quickly
than they otherwise would
i think they could kind of look at it
both ways there really i mean you know
i'm sure they're still putting out hope
for trying to keep desean watson
definitely but
but they gotta like what they saw from
the matthew stafford trade the other day
to realize
wait okay i mean we're we're definitely
gonna get three first rounders that's
that's
like not even a question to me it's like
are we gonna get it to where we get
multiple teams going after it and
they're going to get four first-rounders
i think that's really where we're going
with the desean watson conversation
again this is a guy that's going in the
fifth year of his career
and he's got 10 years left barring some
crazy injury and it would have to be
something crazy but he's just starting
to scratch
the prime of his career so that's where
i think it goes now
where does it go with desean watson and
the texans is the big question mike
and i've been led to believe this mike
that there is no way desean watson will
play for the houston texans again yeah
i'm saying that
i have been told by somebody i trust
that says desean watson will not
play for the houston texans ever again
and he's willing to sit out football for
the year
if he has to that's where i've been led
to to
understand this situation and where it's
at right now and like i said it's
someone i trust very much well and
that's the way the wind's been blowing i
mean the other alternative is show up
and be a pain in the butt like jalen
ramsey was in jacksonville and watson's
not going to do that he's not going to
take a
page from the to playbook get suspended
by the team and go home and do
driveway sit-ups without his shirt on
and that's why he
waited to say trade me we've been over
that he waited because once he says it
he's locked in he's locked into that
strategy which is i'm never coming back
you're done now look it's 5.4 million
per year and unearned signing
signing bonus money that he would owe
the team for every year that he sits out
he'd be giving up
uh his salary he'd have i think the
total number
is near two million dollars in daily
fines for skipping training camp
another hundred thousand dollars for
skipping mandatory mini camp so
he's got the money and uh you know
the message is and and i think here's
the thing and we're going to play
some of what was said on friday but i
think the texans are getting the message
that this guy's done and now they have
to figure out what they're going to do
moving forward david culley introduced
on friday as the head coach
nick casario doing the introduction cal
mcnair jack used to be
not in the building to answer any
questions about the situation
here's caserio and cully on the desean
watson problem the texans are facing
the only thing i knew about this whole
situation at that point was is that i
was being interviewed for
for this job to be the head coach and i
did know at that point
desean watson is a houston texan he's a
quarterback of the houston texans
and that's all that i was concerned
about
and that's all i knew and and whatever
was being
said about what was been what he wanted
to do or he didn't want to do
all i know is this having been in this
business this long
you know he is a houston texan and
i want him to be a houston texan and the
reason i'm in this position today is
because i knew he's going to be a
houston texan
organizationally um just want to
reiterate our commitment to deshaun
watson
um he's had a great impact on this
organization a great impact on a lot of
people
great impact on this team and we look
forward to the opportunity to spend more
time with them here this spring once we
get started
and you know we have zero interest in
trading the player
we have a great plan a great vision for
for him and for this team and his role
in our team
and we look forward to the opportunity
to spend more time with him here this
spring
nick may have committed a faux pas there
when he said we have zero interest in
trading the player because that prompted
deshaun watson that may have prompted
deshaun watson he didn't say why he did
it but the next day he scrubbed the
texans from all of his social media
accounts which
some people say that doesn't mean
anything it means everything and he
referred to himself as an athlete
he referred to himself as an athlete uh
and i had a general manager reach out to
me i had a gm reach out to me and say
why did casario
say we have zero interest in trading the
player i mean you know he's trying to
play a bill parcells card here look
there was more that casario said
and and specifically chris when he was
asked about the timeline for making a
decision
he said we take everything day by day
all he had to say at that point was
there's no timeline because there's no
decision we're not trading him
so there's nothing to talk about here
we're not idiots to borrow the mark
murphy phrase from last week
there was nothing that casario said
during
the press conference that made me think
that they are
in a position where they will not budge
they need to say
we have zero interest it's rick spielman
saying we have no intent to trade percy
harvin all over again
right but at the same time
it was not the kind of hard line
intractable
we're not budging we're not moving this
guy plays for us or plays for no one
that was his chance to tell the world
we love deshaun watson he has a
contractual commitment to us for the
next four years
he just signed it fewer than five months
ago if he had a problem with us then
he should have told us something about
it we want him
we love him we need him desean watson is
a member of this team
and i'm sorry if this seems aggressive
but he plays for us
or he doesn't play for anyone that's how
we view it they didn't say anything
remotely close to that
the doors open the windows cracked and
now
now they've been given this gift with
the matthew stafford trade because they
can sell it or at least try to
as matthew stafford's worth two ones and
a three
that's the starting point for deshawn
watson even though i don't think that's
accurate because
again it's two ones and a three plus you
took jared goff off of our books
yes right right well you know
i think the first thing that that i
would like to comment off there is like
i mean you're right houston could have
probably approached it a little
differently
but they're in a delicate spot i don't
know
i mean my thought would be mike just
after hearing you say that and like
if they made that really strong stand
like he's gonna be a houston texan and
that's all there is to it
that that's a strong stance to take you
could hurt the relationship with desean
watson i think if you came out there
that defiant
well i know i heard it at this point
well but
they don't know that yet they they're
still thinking it's salvageable at least
i would think
before you start going down that road
and like starting to draw lines and
sands and things like that so we'll see
where it goes we'll see
but still like to you're what you're
saying right there it doesn't really
matter what they say
and and deshawn watson has a lot of
power in this situation yeah because the
money he's making
i understand that he is the quarterback
you don't want a disgruntled quarterback
in your locker room and there's
legitimate
reasons to not want to be there
it's the most dysfunctional organization
and football
right from my understanding he is a guy
who came from nothing growing up
he's already got a god of money and he's
going if i got to sit out a year
fine and i've been told he's got the
support of his team that the team
realizes how dysfunctional things are
and they're even going like get out of
here while you can
so between that and i know everybody
looks at it goes well he signed a
contract
well man there's been a lot of crap
that's gone wrong there since he signed
the contract
things can change and he could have been
maybe even a little bothered by the way
things were being run at that point
anyways let alone now to your point mike
we got the jack easter b all-stars
coaching the team
and we don't know how he feels about
that oh prior relationship with nick
casario hey come down
hey oh i'm you know i've got the owner's
ear nope
hey david cully oh that's right i got a
prior relationship with him too and
worked with him with the kansas city
chiefs
you know so all i mean let alone what
happened to the media girl
and some of the other things that have
gone on between
you know the organization i can totally
understand and he's totally
justified to be upset and not like the
houston texans right now
and this is something that shereen and i
talked about on friday's pftpm it feels
like a lot longer ago than it was
you don't say no to general generational
wealth first of all if you're desean
watson they put that kind of offer on
the table you do not say no to it and
also
you know you'll hear the curmudgeonly
comments from certain folks that he
signed a contract he must honor the
contract there's two contracts
that apply to every nfl player contract
between him and the team
and the broader contract between all
players and the national football league
generally and the collective bargaining
agreement
gives players rights he can choose
to withhold services if he's willing to
pay the price
and chris the point you made i've heard
as it relates to other players who get
to the nfl and have come from nothing
different context
different setting but when you are
dealing with a guy
who grew up with nothing and survived
he has no fear of going back to nothing
right right not that he wants to not
that he
he aims to not that he aspires to not
that he's trying to
but he doesn't fear it because he's
already been there
he's already survived it and if he has
to survive it again
he will and yeah for desean watson i
have to get back some of this money but
i still got a lot more than i had
growing up
so i can see where that's coming from
and again and here's the other problem
we have seen nothing from the texans
that cause us to believe that they know
how to read the room
that they have any amount of
self-awareness that's what makes this so
fascinating
the rest of us know exactly where this
is going and i feel like the texans are
the last ones to figure it out
and i don't know whether it's willful
ignorance
but there seems like there's a certain
amount of ignorance as to how it got
here
and where it goes from here and i bet
they'd be hard-pressed to articulate
exactly what went wrong
because they won't admit it's us oh we
don't know what went wrong he
woke up on the wrong side of the bed one
day i guess i don't know we didn't
change anything
when the reality is plenty has changed
for the texans over the past few months
as easter bee has gotten more and more
control
right let alone there was concerning
things before that whether it was dwayne
brown deandre hopkins
you know i mentioned the media girl
before i did not mean to be offensive
there
amy palcik right that that whole issue
we certainly have heard our
our amount of rumors and things like
that to where we realize
we think she was fired because of
political reasons basically
i mean so there's issues across the
board here
and i'm sure when deshawn watson signed
the contract extension
and billy o'brien was still the head
coach at the time
and all of those type of things there
was probably things he didn't love about
the organization
but maybe was just okay i can deal with
this maybe it'll get better
and maybe this year and i don't know
what that moment is or what that thing
was
but this year maybe it just all came to
a head where he went man it's one thing
after another
we're a disaster what are we thinking
what are we doing
let alone the coaching search and that
disaster
and involving him and then not involving
him so uh i don't see how it gets
repaired and i think i you know i don't
think desean watson is the kind of guy
that bluffs in this kind of game
he's not out that's that's why he went
that's why
he waited to say it he wanted to be sure
that he was ready
to go forward with what that means once
you say
trade me and look we've been around him
he seems like a guy
who spends a lot of time listening and
studying
and observing and he's had so much time
to listen and study and observe
in that organization and that's what
made it so striking
at the end of the season he had a press
conference after their their week 17
loss i assume it was a loss because hell
they most of them were losses but
but you know his the things he said and
his comments about how they need a
foundation and they need leadership
and they look they need so much and he
knows it and and at one level
you know he probably feels a little bit
of guilt for abandoning his teammates
but if his teammates are on board with
it too if they realize what a mess it is
and they're like hey deshawn go
save yourself have the career that you
deserve have a patrick mahomes type of a
career
with a better organization you know i i
think at a certain point
nobody justified to say i'm getting out
of here texans
right but nobody wants to play for the
houston texans right now nobody
i mean you've heard i mean jj watts
captain america
mr goody two-shoes and he's letting you
know that it ain't that cool down there
right now
nobody no player in their right mind
wants to go down there and play for that
football team right now
now there's only 32 teams you can play
for and there's a salary cap
and free agency and there's only so much
money to go around so guys are going to
be there
but if it was just apples to apples and
guys went wait there's
houston and another team and i'm getting
the same exact offer and the
same exact opportunity to play they're
going to take the other team
there's no doubt about that i've talked
to too many people and players around
the league who look at houston right now
and go
why would you want to go play for them
yeah it's it's hazard pay that you have
to add to the free agency offers the
raiders were in a stretch like that
15 years ago where it was so
dysfunctional they had to overpay
to get guys to choose to play that was
the only way you were going to stand out
from the other offers that that were
made you know i
i i've been wondering whether or not
nick casario has sought out any advice
from bill belichick on how to handle
this situation with desean watson and i
think belichick would be very pragmatic
i mean
how do you run a successful team if your
franchise quarterback
doesn't want to be part of it how do you
do it right how do how do you pull that
off
now if he's never going to show up it's
never an issue but if he's making it
clear that that he doesn't want to be
there and he means it and i think
caserio is the one guy
in the midst of this storm of
dysfunction who has an opportunity
to realize which way the wind's blowing
and i do think his comments from friday
imply that he gets it that he knows
that this is something they're going to
have to do what's in the best interest
of the texans well
as teams begin to pile up draft picks on
our doorstep
at a certain point it's in the best
interest of the texans
to take those draft picks and move on
from desean watson
and then you have to sell it to the fan
base after that but i think part of it
too
you know the fan base i'd say for the
most part accepts
what's going on and they probably
support it i haven't gotten a whole lot
of
of how dare desean watson won out of
houston feedback now it may be coming
but i haven't gotten much of it if
anything the fans of that team
uh support what he understands what he's
thinking
and what he wants to do and as he gets
more and more real
that pushback that that we saw and how
different the world
is than it was with terrell owens 15
years ago when he simply wanted
greater security from the eagles after
playing with a broken
bone in his leg in the super bowl being
the best player on the field that day
nine catches for 122 yards would have
been the mvp
if the eagles had won the game and he
wants his contract to be reworked and
the eagles attitude was
you signed a contract we're not doing
anything deal with it
and he jostled and agitated now he did
he go about it the right way
no but but that was after every effort
behind the scenes to work it out
failed but the fans were 95 lined up
against him
the world has changed it's encouraging
in the 15 years since to went down i
think more fans understand
that that players have a voice they have
rights
and not that they can just dictate
wherever they want to be and rip up
contracts willy-nilly but there are
going to be circumstances where guys
have a legitimate reason
to want something different than what
they have and i think people are more
willing to listen
now than they were back when owens was
going through it
yeah agreed totally agreed yeah just
it's too many we've had too many marquee
players in our big sports in our country
i think that have made at least the the
fans
a little more numb to that right i mean
we've seen peyton manning on a different
team
and you know tom brady on a different
team and of course lebron james the the
biggest sports star in
in the world changing teams and doing
that so you're right
the public fan bases have certainly got
you know their heads wrapped around that
a little bit more the players have
realized
their power in the situation and listen
what i'll always argue
you know why at times when you have like
you know one let's take two guys they're
both
equal as players one guy gets drafted
and gets put in this situation and he's
got a shamrock up his butt wow look at
this team and this coaching staff i got
the other guy who did nothing to deserve
he gets
drafted by some team and they stink and
they can't get it ever right
so what a lot of these players will look
at and go why am i just going to let
like
the roll of the dice affect my whole
career and how i'm viewed as a player
wait that guy got lucky i didn't oh i
can make my own luck and try to move on
that that way
you're starting to sound like someone
who is warming up to the idea
that the draft is an answer no i'm not
exercise
you're warming up to it because you're
you're basically saying the same things
that i've been saying these guys should
get to pick their teams coming out of
college
the same way they get to pick their
teams going into college
they should be able to do that with
their eyes open now maybe watson still
would have picked the texans because
things were maybe different
four years ago but you're starting to
sound like that guy be careful
you're getting dangerously close to
signing on to my no draft petition
i'm not getting that close don't worry
no i'm not i'm not
but i do think in situations like this
where you have a guy that's a proven
commodity
and knows and we all know and this is
again this is what i love about the
deshaun watson thing this year
no everybody anybody who watches
football even the most novice of fans to
the greatest of fans
can look at desean watson and go he is
definitely one of the five best
quarterbacks in football
and then we can go wait their team was
still four and 12.
yes you got to build a team have
something around them that way
it doesn't matter how good you are you
got to have
something and i think these proven
commodities like it desean watson the
superstar where they start to realize
wait they're going to be judged on their
legacy and every little thing they go
he's watching patrick mahomes who's got
this great support system this whole
time he's in the draft class with him
he's going
what the hell it's probably like you
know mourinho and elway to
a degree where they're looking at each
other and competing and he wants weight
i want the support system my home's got
i think i'm is just as good
and that's playing into this and i think
that's why he's going to make his own
moves and make his own luck
so here's what i think the texans need
to do because i think the texans can
still turn this into a positive once
they accept the fact that they're going
to have to move on from deshaun watson
once they realize
they're not going to have him in 2021
right whether he's
he's on the team or not whether he's on
the roster or not he's not going to be
with them once they come to that
conclusion then
it's time to figure out a strategy i
think that they need to make it known
that the price of admission to come to
the table for the desean
watson contract auction is three
first-round picks you gotta show up with
three first round picks
and once you're at the table we're gonna
figure out
who gets him and it may be and this is
where the
skill is gonna come into play here this
is where casario's gonna earn his money
if you can pit a couple of teams against
each other
to where they start throwing more onto
the pile
to be the one to get the guy that's how
you get the maximum amount
for deshawn watson and i think it's
perfectly reasonable
in light of the matthew stafford trade
and let's gloss over the whole golf
aspect of it to say
we want three and i was told that i i
took a poll of several general managers
three weeks ago
three first job picks and it helps if
one of them is a top 10 pick this year
and you know what maybe maybe the
carolina panthers are the next team
to make that call maybe that's the
signal that if they're willing to give
up the eighth overall pick
for matthew stafford plus more maybe
it's
eighth overall pick two more first round
picks
teddy bridgewater deal gets done
mike i i think that's the interesting
thing about the stafford trade this
weekend
look at the teams that were involved i'd
have a hard time thinking
other than the rams who are now have a
quarterback i would think all those
teams are going to be involved in
talking for deshaun watson plus new
england and i don't know i never heard
anything like tangible as far as how
how interested washington was in matthew
stafford
i had heard there was interest but i
don't know how much but
you know what are the teams we heard
that were involved with stafford let's
just go through it i mean
new england at a base level maybe but
let's just throw them into the sean
watson conversation
carolina denver broncos 49ers
um who else am i missing mike i'm
missing some other team that was
involved in the stafford
uh talk um i i think he got all and
washington was at the table washington
was
okay so those teams you've got to
imagine
are going to be involved in this let
alone maybe some sleeper teams
like the new orleans saints if i'm them
i'm calling up
hey what's it take my team's ready to
win the super bowl who gives a damn
about my next four
first round picks we're ready now i i i
think there's gonna
i really think this weekend made me
think
desean watson is gonna get four
first-round picks it's not three
it's gonna be four because these
you can only go out three years so it's
going to have to be a team that has
multiple first ones
to put on the table you can't go beyond
2023 with your with your draft picks
that you trade
but but the jets have four over the next
two years
so there are teams out there that could
do more than three
yeah miami probably can too right with
their situation
and see how that plays out but that's
again too where your quarterback thing
comes into play as well you're right
whether like will houston go okay fine
you know here's you give us three first
rounders oh and we have a teddy
bridgewater
or the 49ers okay three first rounders
and we got a jimmy garoppolo
at least so now they can go okay we got
the draft pick so we got a quarterback
to at least bridge the gap for a while
and maybe he's the guy
i think those are going to be things to
watch out for as we go along
i agree with you i think the teams that
were interested in matthew stafford are
the baseline the starting point of the
teams that will be interested
in desean watson because why wouldn't
you be and also
also you know there may be other teams
that were interested in staff that we
don't know about because those teams
don't want it out there because they
don't want to undermine
their current quarterback it's entirely
possible the dolphins kicked it around
and i don't know this
but i could see why the dolphins
wouldn't want it to be known that they
did because if you don't get the guy
you don't want to show anything other
than full confidence in the guy that you
have so
these are just the ones that we know
about it's entirely possible that
someone spoke to the lions
under a clear and unequivocal commitment
that that name will never come out so uh
there could be more
and there likely will be more when
deshaun watson is
available assuming he will be and i
think that it's just a matter of time
before the texans realize
that it's a deal they need to do and i
think the timeline even though
nick casario said day to day chris i
think the timeline is before march 17.
you want to get this deal done
because teams start exiting the table
when they have to go
elsewhere to make arrangements at
quarterback you can't keep
six seven eight teams waiting on what
you're gonna do with sean watson
while other quarterbacks make their
decisions about where they're gonna be
no that's exactly right and it's a year
where we know there's gonna be a lot of
musical chairs with these quarterbacks
and
and a lot of action to where teams are
not going to sit around in forever and
wait for this to play out and then lose
their chance at three other quarterbacks
you're right and it's going to be
i mean to me it's as far as i've been in
this business since playing
i don't remember a year ever like this
with the quarterbacks the big names
you know recently high draft picks that
might be available
through free agency and trades this year
pretty remarkable
we mentioned terrell owens earlier in
this segment i remember when he was
acquired by the eagles at his
introductory press conference
andy reid mispronounced terrell owens
first name
um and that was still a better press
conference than what we saw on friday
when they introduced nick ciriani
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports